[Music]
candidate Donald Trump told the American
people he was going to move the US
Embassy in Israel from Tel Aviv to
Jerusalem but President Donald Trump
despite rumors hasn't done the deed now
every Republican candidate has always
promised to do this not have ever done
it
so are they rethinking putting the u.s.
embassy in Jerusalem or are they just
going slow on that one reason the
president may be hesitating is because
of Israeli settlements policy to which
he's expressed some small objection
another reason may be that he just isn't
sure how to do it there's nothing really
wrong with the idea after all West
Jerusalem isn't disputed territory East
Jerusalem is what the Palestinians claim
the real question here isn't where the
embassy is the real question is what is
the basis for peace between the Israelis
and the Palestinians the basis for peace
is a partnership not about where the
different buildings are moving it isn't
going to make all the difference having
a Palestinian partner is what do you
think about moving the US Embassy from
Tel Aviv to Jerusalem let us know in the
comments and also let us know what other
topics you'd like AEI scholars to cover
in 60 seconds